he's got 13. josh richardson inside
blocked by tatum jason tatum shaking his
head saying not here
brown in transition for three
250 pounds he'll make this easy jumper
walker inside great pass by tatum to
canter
entry pass to tatum the frustration at
the end of the play watch joel embiid
like hey
what's happening here
tatum into the paint off the curl
whistle foul got it
jason tatum is here he has been
selective with his two point
opportunities this year but this
is a very good one and how about the
touch he's got 13.
josh richardson inside blocked by tatum
jason tatum shaking his head saying not
here brown in transition for three
jalen brown with the jumper looks like
the
offensive player has a beat jaylen brown
opportunistically pushed it in
transition
gets himself space to the three in a
nice little run
i mean double embed and he turns it over
smart to steal
brown ahead of the pack puts it down and
he is fouled
from smart to ignite the break well good
double team by tatum
gets pressure on him beat he throws it
away
here's jalen brown trying his second
three and connects
on his second three ball dribble hard at
that defensive player
23 years old with significant upsides
still to come
this one to the backcourt off the
deflection three to shoot
tatum kind of let it go for an extra
beat and he banks it in
he shoots it from 35 feet you falling
when he collided with jason tatum had it
blocked by tatum
slapped and packed against the glass
careless turnover in the half court
he tries to cross the body jason tatum
says no
sir trying to get this back to single
digits by the end of the quarter
step back three
and it take him just absolutely going to
work on al horford
remember that al drives the lane kicks
out to harford sloppy pass and smart to
steal
off the floor what a pass to brown
right-handed jackhammer
mark is smart on the fast break to brown
another dunk and this is a crucial time
right here
because you know how the other team
wants to attack
and you know philly wanted to go inside
here adidas stan van gundy stephanie
reddy and what a play kemba walker the
theft
and then the nasty finish in the open
floor
by jalen brown
what up it's your boy adam lefkow did
you like that content i know you like
that content hit subscribe
for more of it from bleacher report